not all hope battles are equal while
some are thrilling some do a disservice
to the strongest adventure but almost
all give us plenty of Smashing from
one-on-one gladiator matches to the big
guy facing a whole horde of baddies
here's our picks for all the Hulk's MCU
fights from worst to best if you've
never heard of the Worf effect it's
simple you take the biggest toughest
good guy and you have the bad guy beat
the tar out of him right out of the gate
that way your audience knows the villain
means business this is exactly what
happens in the opening minutes of 2018
Avengers infinity war The Hulk attacks
Thanos only to get easily beaten
unconscious by the mad Titan even if you
forget the fact that this makes no sense
when we consider how well less powerful
heroes like Captain America fare against
Thanos Thanos bout works hard to earn
it's lousy spot on our list because the
green guy never gets his shot at a
rematch worse still we hardly see him at
all in the final battle of 2019 Avengers
endgame treating the Hulk to a taste of
the wharf effect is bad making it his
last major action scene in the MCU x'
decade-long infinity saga that's pretty
unforgivable Avengers age of Ultron
opens with the team reunited and raiding
a Hydra base in Eastern Europe we don't
see a lot of the Hulk during the fight
compared to some of the other heroes but
what we do see is definitely impressive
among other things we get to see the
whole plow into the Hydra bunker
threatening Hawkeye and Black Widow and
walk through it like it isn't even there
we also get some great shots of the Hulk
including during our introduction to
black widows technique of affecting the
Hulk's transformation back to Bruce
Banner in 2017 Thor Ragnarok Thor has
Loki unleashed the fire giant searcher
who fulfills his destiny by destroying
Asgard in the villain hella in the
process you can't defeat me though I
know
the jihad
a searcher demolishes the golden realm
the Hulk returns from his fight with
Fenris the Wolfman no one's bothered to
tell him the plan
so the Hulk does what the Hulk does he
smashes or at least he tries once the
Hulk lands on the Bifrost Thor manages
to stop him from attacking Surtur again
it's one of a bunch of funny moments the
Thor Hulk odd-couple enjoys in Ragnarok
as good as it is we have to admit there
was some disappointment especially since
the Hulk leaping at Surtur was used
predominantly in ragnaroks trailers it's
a great gag but you can hardly be blamed
if you were primed for a full-length
world shattering clash while the other
revenge errs clashed with hella and her
undead army and Thor Ragnarok the Hulk
has another job the green Goliath goes
one-on-one with hellas favorite pet the
giant wolf Fenris their battle has them
topple off the Bifrost and into the
water below Fenris gives the Hulk a good
fight fighting deep into his emerald
hide at one point and ration him around
underwater but the hole gives his canine
foe one last massive punch that sends
the Beast falling into the boy it's a
good fight though it feels like we don't
really get enough of it there are shots
of it here and there in between the
battle on the Bifrost honestly though it
seems like they only bothered with
putting Fenris in this movie at all so
the Hulk had something to do at the end
while everyone else was busy with
character development the battle between
the poor shield pilot who opened fires
on the Hulk during the Man monsters
Helicarrier rampage in the first
Avengers film isn't much of a battle but
it's scary funny and it tells us a lot
about the Hulk early on Maria hill
orders the pilot to engage the whole and
when he opens fire the big guy just gets
mad remember this was the first Hulk out
sequence since 2008 and it lets us know
right away Joss Whedon intents for his
version of the Hulk to be much more
powerful than the one in the earlier
film the very fact that he's able to
survive the explosion of the jet damn
the subsequent drop makes him much more
powerful than the Hulk of the 2008 movie
Bruce Banner doesn't want the other guy
to get involved in the final battle of
Avengers age of Ultron but when Black
Widow pushes him off a ledge she doesn't
give him much of a choice once he and
Widow are on the floating island that
sokovia has become along with the rest
of the team that tells him to go be a
hero and he does at first we don't
really get to see much of it we only get
a couple of shots of Hulk stomping
Ultron's drones before the villains
final assault on the team at the center
of town
but that's when the Hulk gets really
busy with the robot smashing even
destroying robots with his teeth and of
course after vision Iron Man and Thor
turned Ultron into mostly melted slag
the green guy shows up to give him a
punch that sends him flying for miles as
soon as the Hulk's attack on Black Widow
is interrupted in the Avengers and it
was revealed her Savior was Thor any
old-school Marvel fan had to be excited
who wouldn't be up for about between
these two heavy hitters with technology
that could finally do it justice I'd
like the cringe-worthy battle and 1988
see Incredible Hulk Returns this fight
has some great moments but perhaps the
most memorable being Thor's epic hammer
shot the Hulk's face and the Hulk's
failed attempt to lift Neil near for the
most part Hulk dominates the thunder god
during the first match but the two don't
really have the room on the Helicarrier
to truly let loose like they could not
counting the brief flashback montage in
the beginning of 2008 The Incredible
Hulk our first true Hulk out scene in
the MCU is when Bruce Banner is cornered
by his hostile co-workers in the
Brazilian bottling plant while he's
trying to escape the black ops team led
by Emil Blonsky the scene feels more
like something out of a horror movie we
watch Hulk mercilessly bludgeoning the
soldiers with his bare green fists
mostly without us seeing more than
shadows of the beast it makes it that
much more powerful when he finally
reveals himself to Blonsky seconds
before hurling a forklift at him
[Music]
[Applause]
the gladiator battle between Hulk and
Thor and thor ragnarok is classic it's
beautiful to look at it's funny with
callbacks to Natasha's lullaby and
Loki's epic beatdown in The Avengers and
it gives these two powerhouses the
chance to really cut loose it would get
a higher spot on our list except that it
really doesn't make any sense
plot wise the battle serves mainly to
introduce us to Thor's new Raiden esque
lightning abilities and in order to get
there the scene breaks from everything
we've seen in the MCU up until now The
Hulk
utterly dominates Thor in their battle
on Helicarrier in the Avengers and the
only time Thor manages to get the edge
is when he summons me all near which is
shattered on a cliff in Norway at the
time of a sacar battle with Hulk from
what we've seen of the combatants
respective strength and stamina and past
battles Thor shouldn't even last to the
point where he gets his vision a power
from Odin it's a fun battle but it would
have been more fun if it made sense yes
it's a bit of a stretch to call Hulk
Sucker Punch of Thor in the Avengers of
fight but come on it's hilarious it's
also a perfect character moment The Hulk
doesn't play well with others or maybe
on his side at the time being but to
Hulk that doesn't make them friends
it makes Thor someone he's not currently
smashing much he's had plenty of fights
with others but so far the MCU has given
us exactly one big knock down clash
between the Hulk and one of his most
dangerous villains the abomination who
throws down with the green Goliath at
the end of 2008 Incredible Hulk if you
forgive that movie for its failings you
can see that final brawl is one of the
all-time great superhero clashes the
abomination starts off stronger than a
hero but as the fight progresses and the
Hulk keeps getting angrier the Hulk's
increasing strength puts him over the
edge at the end we get the Hulk uttering
his famous catchphrase for the first
time on screen and dare we say it it's
smashing in the comics the Hulk's most
persistent bow isn't a super villain
it's the United States military led by
general Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross The
Incredible Hulk gave us a great example
of this conflict when the army corners
Bruce Banner on a college campus forcing
him to Hulk out and smash his way
through them and smash he does while
this Hulk doesn't express quite as much
physical power as later versions the
battle does a good job showing us
exactly what he's capable of
he's merely annoyed by the bullets and
even Tony Stark's sonic weapons just
increases rage when he sees Betty in
distress we also get a kind of preview
of Captain America when pre abomination
Emil
skee makes a bad choice of trying to
take the whole called solo with his new
super soldier abilities and gets punted
into a tree for his troubles the Hulk's
epic domination of Loki at the end of
The Avengers is an absolute landmark in
the nfinity saga it is first and
foremost one of the funniest scenes in
the MCU the comedy is the main reason
the scene is so memorable
but it actually provides a perfect
climax to one of the film's themes
throughout the Avengers we're hearing
from less Super characters like Nick
Fury who are talking about how the world
is struggling to react to all of these
Thunder gods and unfrozen super soldiers
who are suddenly showing up the Hawks
abrupt and merciless thrashing if Loki
is the perfect reflection of what Nick
Fury is talking about not only have
these heroes become people who can't be
matched by ordinary humans not even an
arrogant alien calling himself a God can
compare to them a lot of people had a
lot of problems with 2015's Avengers age
of Ultron but the Hulk's battle with
Tony Stark's Hulkbuster armor aka
Veronica is a stunning epic battle and
one of the high action marks of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe while the idea
that Tony Stark has armor designed
specifically to take down the Hulk is
lifted straight from the comics the
filmmakers add some wonderful touches
that make perfect sense for example
there's the fact that Stark has to keep
the suit in orbit while he isn't using
it so he can call upon it whenever he
needs it and then there are all the cool
features like being able to turn one of
the suits fists into a trap that grabs
the Hulk's wrist then stops him from
hurting anyone else while he doesn't win
the Hulk makes a good showing
and Tony's apology when he realizes how
mad his opponent is that's one of the
MCS most perfect moments I'm sorry
[Music]
while 2012 The Avengers brought together
heroes from all over the Marvel
Cinematic Universe The Hulk stole the
show in the final battle against Loki's
Chitauri army in New York City he tears
through the Chitauri foot soldiers
easily and he's the character at the
heart of one of the MCS most classic
memorable and satisfying scenes that's
my secret Kevin
I'm always angry
it not only shows us how staggeringly
powerful the Hulk is but it's a great
character moment as well serving as the
final ingredient the Avengers need to go
from being a ragtag group of superheroes
to an actual team check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stop
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]